let's say we have a generic reaction
where reactants turn into products and
our goal is to think about the
relationship between free energy and
this reaction when it comes to
equilibrium
first we need to consider the equation
that allows us to calculate non-standard
changes in free energy delta g
we can think about delta g as the
instantaneous difference in free energy
between reactants and products
and from the equation we see that delta
g is equal to delta g naught plus rt
natural log of q
delta g naught is the standard change in
free energy between reactants and
products
this value refers to the difference in
free energy between reactants and
products in their standard states at a
specified temperature
r is the ideal gas constant t is the
absolute temperature in kelvin and q is
the reaction quotient
at equilibrium the instantaneous
difference in free energy between
reactants and products is zero which
means there's no more driving force for
the reaction and at equilibrium the
reaction quotient q
is equal to the equilibrium constant k
so we can plug in zero for delta g in
our equation and we can plug in k for q
that gives us zero is equal to delta g
naught plus rt natural log of k
if we subtract rt natural log of k from
both sides we get delta g naught is
equal to negative rt natural log of k
this equation is extremely useful
because now we have a relationship
between free energy and equilibrium if
we know the standard change in free
energy for a particular reaction at a
particular temperature we can calculate
the equilibrium constant for that
reaction
next let's go ahead and go through the
math to solve for the equilibrium
constant k to solve for k we need to
first divide both sides by negative r t
so on the right side negative r t would
cancel out we could then rewrite it as
natural log of k is equal to negative
delta g naught divided by rt
and to get rid of the natural log we
need to take e to both sides
which gives us the following equation
the equilibrium constant k is equal to e
to the negative delta g naught divided
by rt
so if we know the value for delta g
naught for a particular reaction and we
know the temperature we can calculate
the equilibrium constant for that
reaction at that particular temperature
let's calculate the equilibrium constant
k for the synthesis of ammonia from
nitrogen and hydrogen and let's do this
for three different temperatures
let's start with a temperature of 298 to
kelvin delta g naught at this
temperature is equal to negative 33.0
kilojoules per mole of reaction
so to solve for the equilibrium constant
k we need to plug in the value for delta
g naught we also need to plug in the
temperature in kelvin and the ideal gas
constant r
the ideal gas constant is equal to 8.314
joules per mole of reaction kelvin and
since we're using joules in the units we
need to make sure to convert the units
for delta g naught into joules per mole
of reaction so negative 33.0 kilojoules
per mole of reaction is equal to
negative 33 000 joules per mole of
reaction still with three significant
digits and once we plug in our
temperature of 298 kelvin notice how
kelvin cancels out and also joules per
mole of reaction cancels out when we do
the math we find that the equilibrium
constant k is equal to e to the 13.3
power which is equal to 6 times 10 to
the fifth notice how equilibrium
constants don't have units
when e is raised to a power the result
has the same number of significant
figures as there are decimal places in
the power since we have only one decimal
place in this power we have one
significant figure for our final answer
since the value for k for this reaction
at 298 kelvin is much greater than one
that tells us at equilibrium there are
more products than there are reactants
so there's a lot more ammonia than there
is nitrogen or hydrogen when this
reaction reaches equilibrium at 298
kelvin
so whenever delta g naught is negative
or you could say delta g naught is less
than zero the equilibrium constant is
greater than one and products are
favored over reactants at equilibrium
for the same reaction for the synthesis
of ammonia let's calculate the
equilibrium constant k at a different
temperature this time it's 1 000 kelvin
and at 1 000 kelvin delta g naught for
this reaction is equal to positive 106.5
kilojoules per mole of reaction
just like the previous example we're
going to plug everything into our
equation to calculate k so we need to
plug in delta g naught the temperature
which is 1 000 kelvin this time and the
ideal gas constant
so we plug in the ideal gas constant the
temperature and delta g naught once
again we had to convert from kilojoules
per mole of reaction into joules per
mole of reaction so joules per mole of
reaction cancels out and kelvin cancels
out
that gives us k is equal to e to the
negative
12.81 power which is equal to 2.7 times
10 to the negative 6.
because we have two decimal places in
the power the final answer is to two
significant figures for this example k
is much less than one which tells us at
equilibrium there are far more reactants
than there are products so at 1000
kelvin if this reaction were at
equilibrium we'd have a lot more of our
reactants nitrogen and hydrogen and only
a small amount of our product ammonia
so whenever delta g naught is positive
or you could say delta g naught is
greater than zero the equilibrium
constant k is less than one which means
at equilibrium there are a lot more
reactants than there are products
and for our last example let's calculate
the equilibrium constant k for this same
reaction this time at 464 kelvin at that
temperature delta g naught for this
reaction is equal to zero
calculating k is a lot easier for this
example because if we plug in zero for
delta g naught k is equal to e to the
zero power which is equal to one and
when the equilibrium constant is equal
to one that means at equilibrium there's
significant amounts of both reactants
and products so if this reaction were to
reach equilibrium at 464 kelvin there'd
be a significant amount of both our
reactants which are nitrogen and
hydrogen and our product which is
ammonia
let's summarize what we've learned about
the relationship between free energy and
equilibrium
the standard change in free energy for a
reaction delta g naught is related to
the equilibrium constant k by this
equation
and if we are using this equation we
know the reaction is at equilibrium
because we found that equation by
setting the instantaneous change in free
energy delta g
equal to
zero
it's very easy to think that delta g
without the superscript naught and delta
g naught are the same thing however they
are very different quantities
for all three of the situations that we
talked about delta g without the
superscript was equal to zero because
the reaction was at equilibrium
however because delta g naught is the
difference in free energy between
reactants and products in their standard
states delta g naught does not have to
be equal to zero at equilibrium delta g
naught is a constant at a particular
temperature just like the equilibrium
constant k and if delta g naught is less
than zero
k is greater than one which means at
equilibrium there are more products than
reactants
if delta g naught at a particular
temperature is greater than zero that
means the equilibrium constant is less
than one which means the equilibrium
there are more reactants than products
and when delta g naught is equal to zero
k is equal to one which means
significant amounts of both reactants
and products at equilibrium